the
the coordination Command Center in
Boston received a report from the
Canadian Expedition vessel a polar
prints of an overdue 21 foot submarine
Titan with five people on board
the Titan was attempting to dive on the
wreck of the Titanic approximately 900
miles east of Cape Cod and 400 miles
south of St John's Newfoundland
approximately one hour and 45 minutes
into the scheduled dive
the polar prints lost all communication
with the Titan the polar prints
conducted an initial search and then
requested Coast Guard assistance the U.S
Coast Guard in Boston assumed the
responsibility of search and rescue
mission coordinator and immediately
launched search assets
since Sunday the Coast Guard has
coordinated search efforts
where the U.S the Canadian Coast Guard
Air National Guard aircraft and the
polar prints which is searched to
combine 7 600 square miles an area
larger than the state of Connecticut
these search efforts have focused on
both surface with C-130 aircraft
searching by sight and with radar and
subsurface with P3 aircraft
were able to drop and monitor sonar
buoys to date those search efforts have
not yielded any results
search efforts have continued through
last night and today
The Vessel deep energy 194 meter pipe
laying vessel arrived on scene with
underwater ROV capability
they have rendezvous with a vessel polar
prints and can commenced an ROV dive at
the last known of the position of the
Titan in the approximate position of the
Titanic wreck that operation is
currently ongoing
additionally a Canadian P3 aircraft is
currently conducting a six-hour search
of the area and several C-130 aircraft
and another P3 are scheduled to fly this
afternoon and this evening
the Canadian Coast Guard Cutter or
vessel John Cabot is scheduled to arrive
later this evening
and several other Canadian Coast Guard
vessels and the Coast Guard Cutter
Sycamore are in route
Additionally the U.S Coast Guard has
the U.S Navy's sub-soul
supervisor of salvaging diving command
is working with U.S Transportation
command to bring additional assets to
the search area
these more capable assets will be staged
out of St John's for further transport
search area
there are also several private vessels
research vessels ROV capabilities that
are making preparations to join the
efforts
so I want to reiterate this is a very
complex search and the unified team is
working around the clock to bring all
available assets and expertise to bear
as quickly as possible in an effort to
solve this very complex problem
we'll continue to provide updates as
they become available
and again our thoughts and prayers are
with the crew and the families and their
loved ones
we will provide unwavering effort as we
continue the search